qu'est ce que tu fous hollywood tu es
venu pour acheter de l'herbe
[Musique]
je fais le montage de ceux de ce film
rabbit et olympique a c'est un autiste
du septième art ce qui veut dire qu'il
vit respire les films et je suis presque
certain qu'il est encore puceau
j'ai eu une idée sur un grand requin
blanc qui aurait une ville de la côte
genre une ville de nouvelle angleterre
en robot requins kouao bon requin
pourquoi we salute robot vous deux vous
combien de filles qui sait elle
soledad
j'ai entendu dire que c'était une garce
je peux lui parler son copain après du
lsd lui a mordu le nez alors elle a
sauté par la fenêtre et séduit
bienvenue à hollywood petit je veux bien
me prendre le montage ici la brave new
york travailler sur un projet je vais
monter votre film qu'est-ce que ça c'est
de me voir mourir j'adore pouvoir
j'ai créé un film de guerre
cauchemardesque napalm armés ou des
sauvages drogue
on est au coeur des ténèbres si tu vois
ce que je veux dire une impression des
grilles allait vraiment je m'appelais
moving c'est pas ton film c'est le mien
mais qu'il est même encore plus t'as pas
du tout
[Musique]
tu veux dire si je savais que ça allait
devenir un film génial super ton cadeau
d'offres quelque chose de spécial pour
fêter ça pour qu'ils ont bien tu vas
t'éclater ce soir un film vraiment
étrange